in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Stephen
and Shelley are with us hey guys how are
you it is welcome welcome good to have
you where do you guys live College
Station Texas Oh Aggie land yes sir all
right well welcome to Nashville we're
glad you're here and here to do a
debt-free scream yes sir how much have
you paid off two hundred eighty-five
thousand five hundred eighty dollars in
sixty three months I love it very well
done
making what kind of money during that
time five years ago we're making seventy
eight thousand a year and now we're up
to one hundred fifty thousand year whoa
doubled your income yes sir
Wow what do you guys what what what do
you attribute to doubled income - well I
graduated with my master's in nursing
and you got a promotion ah very good
okay so one-two punch there very good
good so 286,000 what was that that you
paid off well there were two car loans
two mortgages and a student loan okay so
the two mortgages paid off your home we
did we had a rental that we paid off and
and our primary residence so you are
100% debt free paid for houses were made
for rental paid for degrees paid for
everything yep wow that's fun yes
congratulations so sixty three months is
a journey that's serious I mean you've
been fighting through getting your house
paid off that's quick to pay off your
house though well five years six years
ago we we did refinance to a 10-year
note and said you know what we don't
want to wait ten years we want to get it
done before that yeah
and we did and then you knocked out the
other stuff first and of course then
went after the houses and so forth very
cool so what happened sixty three months
ago that started you on this journey was
it something you are already doing or
what was going on well it actually
started a little while ago for me I was
just sick and tired of stealing from our
future kind of a turning point for me
was when and we took out a second on a
previous home in order to transfer debt
from a kids student loan and some
consumer debt and then when we
sold that house for actually quite an
increase in value
we didn't take any of the equity with us
because it all was already spent on that
other stuff exactly and then 63 months
ago actually we got a little help on
this journey from a sad event my father
passed away left us some money which we
used to knock out the car loans and my
student loan uh-huh
and then we just said we got to do this
now okay so we're gonna lean in and
knock these houses out then so what's
the rental property that's paid for
worth well we actually sold that oh you
said with vodka we sold that at a loss
that was one of those things we we
bought for our kids who are in college
we thought it'd be a good investment
uh-huh but you know it was vacant for
several months very seldom does that
work out yeah that's always a good
theory when you're talking about it but
it never works out yeah so you got rid
of that and the hole now is paid for
what's your home worth 225 okay
excellent very cool you guys are doing
great we are doing great you got a feel
amazing so how long have y'all been
married um sunday will be our
anniversary 24 years good job good job
you played that right good very well
that we're on the trip to Nashville you
better get the number right yeah okay 24
years have you ever been debt-free since
you got married no I don't think I've
ever been debt free period right yeah
and you know it was the second marriage
for both of us and you know he had his
thing and I had my thing because we had
kids from previous marriages we kept
everything separate and when we finally
brought our finances together we we
started winning yeah and it was quite
amazing and it brought us closer
together - absolutely well 24 years is
fair yeah that's good
congratulations you guys I'm proud of
you you got to feel great how's it feel
you don't have any payments to have no
payments and in one of the one of the
things I like I really enjoy is
everybody I work with knows that I have
a $20 a week allowance uh-huh and they
always make fun of me yeah except they
told him you know what I'm debt free and
I'm not broke yeah
this is by choice right that's exactly
right
so what do you tell people the key is
you've paid off your home you paid off
everything when they find out that
you're dead free what do you tell them
the key to getting out of debt is well
we believe that there are really three
critical elements involved first of all
is you have to believe that it's the
smart thing to do and the right thing to
do and that it's possible and you know
the concept of actually paying for a
cash for a car with cash the second
thing was staying motivated and for me
that was staying plugged in and I found
the podcasts were very inspirational and
just kept pushing me along and in the
communication between the two of us was
critical and then finally the monthly
budget we always had a budget but it was
more like a figurehead yeah it never
really ruled us ah that's a good way of
saying it yeah they have to have an
actual benevolent dictator of a budget
not just a figurehead yeah that's
excellent guys very very well done I
love it well thanks for coming to
Nashville to do your debt-free scream
you know there's one more thing that I
would really like to mention I want to
thank your team member Todd Ward who has
been helping us to get the foundations
for personal finance into the College of
Nursing at Texas A&M we're very excited
about that
you're - yeah I'm hoping to help my
students learn how not to do what we did
you know that that starting now instead
of waiting 20 years to save for your
future makes a huge difference makes all
the difference in the world and Todd
does do a great job working with
colleges all over America he really does
well congratulations you guys again
again again all right Steven and Shelley
College Station Texas two hundred and
eighty six thousand dollars paid off in
sixty three months making seventy eight
to 150 a year
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one
weird excellent job excellent excellent
excellent hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim